mathieu brigands et sapeurs pompiers
depuis 15 ans à dijon et il le reconnaît
depuis quelques années les interventions
sont de plus en plus difficile pour lui
et ses collègues avec des agressions
qu'il faut aujourd'hui presque partie du
quotidien
la bassine patients et au final ma
collection dégoûté parce que le stress
on se fait menacer en là moi même la
semaine dernière
sur intervention je me suis fait menacer
cracher dessus il a fallu contentieux de
la personne dans la zone armée a été
avec nous cette agression n'a pas eu
lieu dans un quartier dit sensible
les pompiers ont aujourd'hui autant de
risques d'être pris à partie en ville
qu'en milieu rural
un vrai changement qui s'explique en
partie par l'évolution des missions
nous intervenons de plus en plus dans un
cadre d'urgence sociale est presque de
moins en moins dans un cadre d'urgences
médico secouristes alors que normalement
ça doit être notre coeur de métier mais
c'est effectivement lié une
malheureusement une évolution un petit
peu un petit peu défavorable de notre
note société avec des gens qui nous
appellent parce que je considère
qu'avoir des secours n'est pas un droit
mais des conditions d'exercice auquel
les nouvelles recrues sont vite
sensibiliser comme à la présence
aujourd'hui dans les rangs des pompiers
de côte-d'or de quatre psychologues ils
peuvent les aider à surmonter le
traumatisme d'une agression c'est
vraiment important que vous puissiez
d'hébreu mans nous consulter au moment
où vous en aurez besoin
ces futurs pompiers volontaires
partiront en intervention dans quelques
jours conscients des risques qu'ils
courent ça n'entache pas ma motivation
je pense que les gens qui sont amenés à
agresser des pompiers ce qu'ils sont ils
ont certainement perdu des repères je me
formalise pas là dessus je reste
convaincu que l'action que moi je mène
elle est positive pour les gens et c'est
ce qui prend le dessus verbales ou
physiques le nombre d'agressions de
pompiers a été multiplié par trois en
dix ans